it is july 1st 2022 so it's time for
another monthly update video i'm going
to talk about what went on in june that
you might have missed and you might want
to check out
and what we've got coming up in this
long month of july
so i always like to highlight three big
things and big thing number one is we
are moving classic metal class onto the
light hall platform there's a link if
you do the show more in this video you
can see a link to classic metal class
this month we're going to be discussing
a very
interesting set of topics
big thing number two this is more of a
heads up keep your eyes open if you're
into things stoic keep your eyes open
for an announcement about stoicon and
the lineup uh stowacount is going to
happen october 29th the international
online big event
and we're lining up our speakers for
that now so by the end of the month
there will be an announcement about that
and the third big thing if you're into
philip k dick well
last month was a good month for you and
this coming month is going to be a good
month for you because we actually
discussed android's dream of electric
sheep slash the blade runner in the
wisdom for life show
and i'm going to be putting out more
videos about dick that i'll tell you
about in the
july portion
what took place in the month of june
well i held my usual online events an
ama session uh hegel q a and discussion
sessions scott truly and i had a great
classic metal class where we discussed
um who should be called an original
member of bands we did some
philosophical analysis and some music
history
worlds of speculative fiction we did
veronica roth's carve the mark universe
which was quite cool i also got to
go to a
book event
um
you know for a lo well local chicago
author that was held up here in
milwaukee
uh dare to know was the name of the book
it's a really good fiction book and so
that was kind of fun um i did a series i
wrapped up a series rather of stoic
sundays
online we could call them video classes
or whatever and i'll probably take that
back up again later on this summer
we've been doing a lot of things out and
about in town i've been going for walks
and you know taking pictures of
the beautiful flowers and landscape and
things going on and picking a lot of
wildflowers too
i've been getting back to the gym as
well for
exercise and my wife andy and i have
been going to a lot of concerts and
other events it is the
summer concert season
because summerfest is here the world's
largest music festival held here in
milwaukee we also you know saw some
other things you know for example
sticks and an reo speedwagon with
loverboy before summerfest we went to
uh murder on the orient express a really
well put together play we attended
dennis de young's hunchback of notre
dame here and we wrapped up the
milwaukee symphony orchestra concert
season with the very last show of the
season which was uh pretty spectacular
so a lot of stuff going on we also went
to the zoo ball which is a gala we we
went to two galas now that i think about
it one was for the performing arts
center and one was for the zoo so you
get dressed up and you know you go to
a dinner and there's drinks and auctions
and stuff like that and so that's what
we've been up to
and sometimes andy's mom would come
along sometimes it's just us
i've been doing a good bit of writing
i published a piece in stoicism today
and in the online magazine the stoa i've
been doing a good bit of writing and
medium as well that you may have seen
i also did an interview for val in vogue
who wanted to talk about heavy metal and
philosophy and so that's that's pretty
cool i'll put a link to that below
and i started two classes one of which
is an academic class for milwaukee
institute of art and design my online
six week intro to philosophy class
and that's a lot of fun we're now
in
week two finishing it out
moving into week three
and a lot of cool stuff going on there
and with light hall i
started teaching an online class meeting
weekly for eight weeks on aristotle and
the
moral virtues very excited about that
it's going quite well we've had one
class session next week we're getting
into
courage and temperance and then we're
proceeding onward
i did a lot of uh video work but i
didn't necessarily get all the video
work that i had originally planned i
only got one half hour hegel video done
and only one book review video done and
so i really wanted to get more on those
but i did do some other cool stuff core
concept videos
from my business ethics uh classes and
thing you know authors i'm teaching i
did something on robert audi and he's
got some really great observations about
virtue ethics uh john hospers what is
libertarianism uh short little video
series on that
um
and you might have seen i've been doing
more speculative fiction videos
speculative fiction studies videos and
they've been on philip k dicks to
android's dream of electric sheep
contained in this lovely uh library of
america volume you notice the little
things there because i'm
filming fairly soon some some more dick
stuff
and uh what else i did um
you know
another fake quotes video about plato
some of the most egregious fake quotes
and i solicited you know ideas about who
else i should do them on
i
shot some stuff
about
you know
sassy i did a hour-long tribute video
finally if you don't know our cat sassy
19 years old passed away a couple months
ago and i finally got around to taking
all the video footage and
creating that
um
i
took the recording from a light hall
class and and published that on on
epictetus and stoic practices there's
actually two videos on that out there
and i did another sadler's asides uh
digressions and rants video people seem
to like those i'm gonna keep doing them
i did a quick take video about whether
you should listen to past selves or not
and i just finished up the month with a
video that i thought would be kind of
helpful for people because they easily
get confused about you know where i've
been and where where i've taught and you
know what sort of positions i've held
about my more than 20 year academic
career
my academic teaching you know started
back in 1999 so i created a video
specifically about the 11 different
places i have taught
podcast
i finished up the epictetus series that
i was working on and then i took a
little
side track into
things about the cynics drawing on
lucian of samosata
xenophon the famous historian and
student of socrates and diogenes laertes
who talks about them in book six of his
lives of the philosophers then i did
some stuff from plato's republic book
six and seven all metaphysical and
epistemological stuff and for i'd say
the last two weeks i have been putting
out podcast episodes on augustine's
confessions and some of the key things
happening in that work so that's uh june
now let's talk about what's coming up
in july i don't have quite as many
events as i had in previous months lined
up in part because andy and i are going
to be doing
a lot of things on the weekends together
going down to alpine valley to see rage
against the machine heading up to
lambeau field on another saturday to see
not a football game well actually it is
a football game but world football we're
going to see a soccer game there which
is quite interesting
and uh you know we've got other things
going on summerfest is still happening
as well but i do have these events lined
up for you now all of them all the times
that i'm giving are in central time so
you do want to check your time zone to
make sure that you arrive when the event
actually starts and you don't miss out
starting tomorrow on the second at noon
we'll have our monthly ama that's ask me
anything session come on in you can ask
questions about philosophy you can ask
personal questions you can ask questions
about heavy metal or literature whatever
you want it's an ama right
later on that day for my patreon
supporters at two o'clock i will be
having the monthly philosophy chat which
is always quite fun that's a little bit
more intimate right a little bit more
interactive then we fast forward all the
way to the 13th at 4 pm now notice
usually i do it at 5 p.m but i got to do
it at 4 p.m because i have to do it
before my class office hours we will be
having our
monthly
patreon supported but free and open to
the public hegel q a and discussion
session
on the 16th scott taruli and i will be
doing our classic metal class and we are
doing something really fun and
interesting for this one by the way it's
going to be hosted on light hall so if
you want to attend it you got to sign up
through
light hall it's totally free
and you'll get uh some some cool perks
like a discography uh with it we're
gonna be talking about rebellion as a
theme
in heavy metal on the 17th which is the
next day and that's a sunday this is a
little bit unusual as well we'll be
having our worlds of speculative fiction
which begins at noon with a video
premiere about an hour and a half and
then we have a hour and a half long zoom
session
we are discussing these rogers aladdin
zelazny's chronicles of amber part two
books
uh six through ten about no longer
merlin but rather are no longer corwin
but rather his son merlin who is a child
both of amber and chaos right you know
if you don't know what that means maybe
read the books and you might enjoy that
so
um
that's going to be coming up on the 17th
at uh
12 p.m as well
um
then on the 28th at 6 00 p.m we will
have our milwaukee stoic fellowship
meeting this is open to everybody
worldwide we have people popping in from
as far away
as brazil
and we're working our way through
diogenes laertes a summary of stoic
doctrines we're deep in the ethics part
now that you can find the link to below
and then finally on the 30th um we're
going to have a
political theory and practice discussion
there's so much going on i don't know
which thing we're going to talk about
yet it's as if like things are hitting
every single week something new
so i'm not quite sure which topic we're
going to explore but we will be
exploring some topics
what else uh video work coming up this
month i'm gonna be continuing the philip
k dick stuff uh by the way
you should if you know tomorrow there's
actually gonna be an airing of wisdom
for life in which uh my co-host and i
are going to be talking about dicks to
android's dream of electric sheep and
the theme of empathy so you're not going
to want to miss that but if you do miss
that we'll have a recording coming up
later that i'll i'll post
half hour hegel i i need to get back up
to you know my quota for this month
we're getting close to the end of the
book and i would like to finish it out
strong i got some book review videos to
do
as well
and i'll be doing some more philip k
dick um
speculative fiction studies on the
android stream of electric sheep but
also on his essay the android and the
human which i think is really quite good
um if i get around to it i'm going to do
some core concept videos on arthur
schopenhauer
not one of the big books but rather one
of the smaller works i'll probably do
some personal you know stories videos as
well and i might do another quick take
or a soapbox video i'll definitely do
another uh hey uh sadler's asides
digressions and rants uh drawing from
the hegel videos
podcast stuff
i'm gonna be doing uh more work on
augustine and finishing out the stuff on
the confessions
then um i'm not sure what order we'll do
it in but we'll do some stuff on
anselm's on truth and plato's fado and
that'll probably keep me busy
for the month because i have a lot of
videos to convert into podcast episodes
for those and i'll be doing more writing
you know you can you can probably see me
there may be a few interviews coming out
that i've done in the past that people
will be
putting out and i might do some
interview videos with other people
myself i'm also thinking about analyzing
aita am i the a-hole cases because i
think those are kind of uh
you know fruitful for moral discussion
and i might do those in the video
channel
as well but we'll see i don't want to
get too ambitious because we get a lot
going on in july still have classes
running getting ready for fall getting
ready for stoicon and all these other
things happening but that's that i hope
that you have a great month ahead and i
hope that i'll see you in some of these
online events and we'll have a great
time
you